thank you everybody um
the original
schedule said hamish watson was going to
be speaking here today hamish is our ceo
as you might hear from my accent my name
isn't a mission it isn't watson
um
my name is roy smith i'm the proposals
manager for for poli solar we have
recently won the tenders for the um
submarine stone market leisure centers
carport
solar projects um just a little bit
about polysolar before we get on to
the the feedback of where we are at the
moment
one of the things is we believe that
every building can become a source of
renewable energy we don't have to go to
um
only rooftop we don't only have to look
at
so this is jumping ahead yeah i'm not
sure why
we don't only have to look at rooftop
solar or ground
solar we can we can look at the building
in the building facades etc
ah there we go back to where we are
and we are doing this by
using transparent pv the projects that
we busy with at the moment is not using
transparent pv but this is just a little
bit of background on on the company
itself we're using it as and what we
call it is building integrated
photovoltaics we use building facades
replacing windows etc with with the pv
some of the companies we worked with
i'm not going to go into any detail of
those at the moment but there's a large
variety of companies that we've worked
with at the moment um as you can see the
the local councils that we're working
with for bible and mid-suffolk are right
there in the middle that is the project
which we're talking about today another
project which is not in the case that is
going forward is shell
shell has
commissioned us to do
transparent pv for their very first
ev-only charging station
in the country so they will not be
selling petrol they would not be selling
diesel it is only
solar that they'll be doing and we're
doing that for them
we've done projects for sainsburys where
we're doing the the petrol station
roofs swimming pools canary wharf we had
one of the very first transparent bus
shelters um generating power in in the
country
the last one there for the sandoval
council
we did a market stall at west bromwich
and again this thing is jumping ahead
without me pressing any buttons
i'm not going to talk much about this
slide the councillors on
on the on their introductions this
morning have
indicated why there is an importance to
go ahead
with
solar just one one thing to point out on
the slide bottom right hand corner
battery costs have
dropped nearly a thousand percent since
2020 2010
which is important because we're using
technology to provide power not fossil
fuels
our product range
we are looking at monocrystalline
silicon which is a traditional silicon
that you use in solar panels but we
embed that in glass we move those
silicon wafers in and out to give an
opaque
a latch transmission through
through the solar panels and we use that
in
carports and canopies
and i'm going to press the back button
and we use cadmium telluride to provide
transparent thin form solar glass that
can be made into
single glazing or double glazing and we
use traditional
monocrystalline silicon as well
the
applications of our
of our solar is we're looking at solar
canopies there we can any shape any size
we we're looking at for for domestic and
commercial use
solar ev carports we've done several
solar ev carports throughout the country
with with it being either traditional
solar or transparent solar and then
solar building facades as i mentioned
earlier the cadmium telluride
transparent solar that we that we
produce
we can use in a building facade it is
designed to work
horizontally it doesn't have to face the
sun so we could use that in in building
facades
some of the case studies again just to
show you the breadth of what we do and
then how that would fit into what we're
looking at for the council we've done a
transport hub at bournemouth university
there we go we've got bus shelters
people using the bus shelter as uh
functional street furniture as well as
generating electricity
west rummage market stalls we've got
about 34 market stalls where we replaced
the canopies that the guys were using
with a solar
solar canopy
another big big job we've done was the
cambridge north uh
station where we covered the cycle
shelter
um bristol and barth at the at the
science park we did ev charging with our
transparent solar solutions
and in the domestic range we we've got a
range of transparent
or semi-transparent
solar carports which can be
used in the domestic environment
and then lastly in the domestic
environment we've got
canopies these garden canopies can be
freestanding set up against the side of
the building etc
okay now to get to the reason why we're
all here we're putting in the solar
carports at sudbury and stone market
leisure centers
that is a graphical representation of
what we will be putting in at those two
at those two sites
kingfisher leisure center you guys
probably know from being from from close
by this is where we're doing it's the
bottom sort of the south car park of the
of the leisure center will be
have a whole lot of solar carpools
reutilizing the existing space it is
owned by the the leisure center we don't
have to to go out and and put it in
green fields um there is a
separate contract of people already
doing pv on the roof but if you
but if you run run out of space on the
roof and you need more power carports is
an
ideal way of
of actually utilizing your existing
space
we're doing at the
mid-suffolk leisure center as well there
we're doing the north side of the of the
building doing a whole lot of carports
there
one of the the main uses of the of the
powers is ev charging um at those two
leisure centers
today there's only a dual uh car charger
at the
sudbury at the kingfisher leisure center
after we finish the project we will have
10 ev charging points we'll be
repurposing the existing car
ev charges for accessible bays and we'll
be adding eight additional
at the stomach site we'll be putting
at the stone stone market site will be
putting in uh 10 ev charging points
uh two of which will be at for the the
accessible base
okay how much power we're going to be
generating we've been contracted to
provide 104 kilowatt peak at
sudbury and 195 kilowatt peak at stone
market
um
technology evolves quite fast we
originally planned to do about a hundred
and five hundred and six kilowatts at
sudbury but we can't get those panels
anymore we're now getting higher power
panels we're going to be doing about 109
kilowatts
and about 198 kilowatts at
at uh at stone market
um
there it shows the the average kilowatts
hours per per year that we're looking at
for the the two sites eighty-seven
thousand and hundred and seventy eight
thousand
the the interesting factor is that just
about 31 tons of co2 per annum
sudbury and 63 tons
at stone market
and the question comes in i mean what
does that actually equate to is that a
lot is that a little
there we've i found a photograph of
what is a representation of one ton of
co2
now there's a fair amount of
space that we're looking at now for
sudbury per annum we're saving 31 tonnes
and so stow market 63 tons
and the the energy that we're generating
also just to put it in perspective
is it's the same power as
24 homes
24 homes in sudbury and average of 52
homes in stone market that is what we'll
be generating
per annum if you equate that to a small
very efficient car not an electric
vehicle
we could be
doing 660
000 kilometers of travel
and that's the energy produced by just
by putting solar on the two carports
that we that we are looking at
i'm going to talk a little bit longer
about this about this slide um what we
are doing is we are putting solar on the
carports we are erecting the carports
which are specifically designed to take
the solar and we are inverting that into
mains electricity and we are feeding
that into the local distribution network
on the site
a fair amount of that power will end up
going into battery storage if it's not
being used immediately the power will
also be used for the ev charging
spoilt
i spoiled the ending there by this this
machine which is jumping ahead by itself
if there is excess power being generated
we could push that back into the
national grid or used into the into the
leisure center
having battery storage ev chargers and
solar on the on your on your site
is fairly
restrictive if you're not managing it
correctly
what we need to do in a case like this
is measure how much where is coming from
the sun
measure how full the batteries are
measure how much power is going out to
the ev charges measure how much is going
into the leisure center and understand
what are your limitations and your your
energy costs from the national grid so
what we do is throw all of that into a
pot come up with the algorithms to say
it is best to charge your batteries at
four o'clock in the morning and use that
power in the ev charges during the day
or there's a weather forecast saying
we're not going to get as much solar
tomorrow as what we expected
where do we get the power where do we
store the power where do we most
efficiently use the power on on the
sites
um
what we could do is uh if if we had a
step tariff
on the power coming in from the national
grid we could say at certain times of
the day if we used more than x amount of
power it would be beneficial to take the
battery power that we stored and push it
back into the grid limiting
your um power consumption on
on the site so the a lot of
effort and energy has been put into
managing the power on the site not only
generating it
a lot of questions that have come up
from the the talks yesterday is when
will we be finished
and um we contracted to finish at the
end of march and we are currently on
schedule to probably finish on the at
the end of at the end of march
a couple of milestones coming up we have
placed the order for all of the
manufacturing of all of the carports so
they're busy being manufactured at the
moment we're busy with detailed design
on the electrical layout
we've more or less got that finalized
more or less finalize what's going to be
happening with the battery storage and
things like that
we've got guys on site in probably two
to three weeks testing the ground
conditions at the exact points where the
foundations will be for the um
for the carports so the project is
underway it is on track and
is going to have significant savings for
the for the local communities
um
if there are any questions um i'll be
more than willing to answer them i will
be at the stand
for the rest of the day so if there are
any questions on this particular project
on any of the case studies we've done
i briefly showed you
you're more than welcome to to ask me
thank you
[Applause]
you